welcome to the league and you got every
guy that is good as they got on the other
side and McKinnon rips the face off away in
a similar fashion to what Sydney Cross we did
The Bard on opening night our starting lineups
brought to you by Taco Bell will scream across
your screen mck kidon one hand on the stick
tries to poke it in deeper gets the return
feet able to work back for Devon lets it fly
from traffic and morazi's in the hockey game
early but the ABS able to jump on it with Jack
Johnson and they're third pair on the Colorado
Blue Line here's an opportunity breaking in as
Nick Felino in back in and Gori have a great
save a little bit of a broken play in Felino
gets into the middle seam Dickinson just swats
the puck to him and he's in front of Josh Manson
he protects the puck and then gorgiev is far far
as he can stretch with his left leg as he goes
with Felino to the forehand that first setup
NuSkin overplaying on Bard he's over way tighter
to Bard to take him and his shot away denado
turns it over far side and Colorado looking
to break there's the opportunity shorthanded
score Logan o Conor has the Avalanche up first
one nothing Hogan were the ab's most aggressive
penalty killing group good play on the boards by
Josh Manson through cogliano and watch o Conor
read and time this perfectly he doesn't get too
far ahead Manson wins that puck battle we showed
that earlier that Colorado's you know when you're
18 years old you learn how where to eat where to
go where to hang out how to work how not to work
too hard at practice save it for a game a little
bit that that's been a bit of an issue lately high
off the shoulder of morazzi might have caught the
crossb contest here's early in that shift marar
gets in the shot deflects off a vasic stick and
morazi's got a fight it wear out some black walks
back to the point Jack Johnson and that shot side
of the net there's drewan 27 and the blue and
maroon turnaround shot rebound is stopped by
moric here's McKinnon he fumbles that puck able
to recover McKinnon was farand one time shot and
stopped raning is robbed by morazzi McKinnon
who's going to Bobble the puck watch him take
a step get away from Jason Dickinson and he goes
across to Ranon and ranin one times this 55 goals
last year ronin's got three already this year
off the goal post morzac goalie's best friend
the iron kind behind him off the face off here's
McKinnon he goes cross i s in front unbelievable
save by moric loose Puck still loose and now
it's in on the power [Music] [Applause] [Music]
play CU we getting exhausted look at
this save by Peter morzac on the right
pad Johansson the rebound then after Murphy
cleans out lacking it Johansson's going to
follow this puck back this is his first
goal as a Cado Avalanche he stays with
it well I mean the most of the time came in the
first portion of the period the last half of the
period going to be hard to get a shot on gold if
the Avalanche had the puck the whole time setting
the stage for Luke Richardson and the rebuild
that was going to go was going to go on a real
positive presence around him turned over in
front morazzi is there again left all alone
as Peter morazzi towards Peter morazzi is a good
four check on to Seth Jones turns that puck over
and Jonathan drwan is wide open he gets two cracks
at it Dickson got it to Felino momentarily and the
ABS will counter and come back to center with some
speed Ross Colton leaves there for drwan Center in
front they score what a pass from Jonathan drwan
and get separation dwan's going to come off the
wall the young defenseman Kinski loses his lane
kinsky ends up one stride too far to the outside
that allows drwan to read step into the middle
and that pass is a bullet it's flat it's on the
tape and Miles wood has his second as a Colorado
Avalanche and marazza can't get this one going to
challenge this for go offside before the goal so
it'll be on that drop pass from Colton to drwan at
the Blue Line and we'll see if that's offside
or not the linesmen Steve Barton and Travis
garwitz are over on the headset and they'll get
plenty of looks that they'll need to make that
call it's the type of play that does go offside
because when you drop the puck it does go sideways
and you're going to you're going to need the view
confirm the play was offside no go please reset
the cl to for2 Joe Hansson got it across left for
ranton gives for mckin inside of the net away from
the sliding Conor Murphy back to the point marar
one time rocket from McKinnon is stopped by moric
that hit him right in The Mask behind the back Ma
has it broken up Taylor radish looking to counter
got some help Rish got it across and that is
stopped gorev the big save there Colton on it
good battle along the wall and it's Lucas rle for
Chicago Tyler Johnson turns it right over oh it's
been a dominant effort by Colorado unbelievable
wide open net for Devon Cav Tic Tac Toe what a
beauty and the ABS do get that third goal back
North and the puck headed south reel turns this
over Johnson doesn't get it out and Taves will
make the pass and stay down rope Ross Colton is
standing in front of Peter morazzi morzac has no
idea where the puck is at this point as Colton's
done a tremendous job screening NuSkin puts it
perfectly t almost misses it actually through
the first four those are heavy minutes against
the other team's best [Applause] players some
15 seconds left of Colorado power play time
to open up period number three three nothing
Avalanche here's rant now on his backand gets the
return feed and snapped it and caught the glass
Boose Chang to Colorado rantman comes away
finds Byrum and across the line the athlet
to set it up here McKinnon dancing it's blocked
down the defense kachuk there he turns it right
over to Jack Johnson Johnson leaves there for
McKinnon RS one through stopped by moric lost
it momentarily and the ABS couldn't jump on the
rebound you're right Ray M him sniffing for one
here's a chance shot he scores right on [Applause]
Ray Nathan McKinnon they get four nothing Colorado
didn't have anything tonight now he's got one
he was on the hunt here a long wrist shot was
stopped earlier Thomas Tatar makes a really nice
play out of the traffic now Tatar was put on this
line mid second period he just lays it out there
and Nate McKinnon's not going to miss from there
last year led the NHL in Five On Five Points yor
evz faced 18 shots on goal from Chicago and those
that have remained after this late start here will
rise as one and salute gorv 14th career shut out